oil extraction continues unabated around
the world
for example here in kuwait there's been
no slowdown even though the market is
saturated and the price has plunged
just two years ago a barrel of brent oil
from the north sea cost 120 dollars
this summer the price of oil fell below
the psychologically significant one
hundred dollar level and now it's just
eighty dollars a barrel
there's too much oil on the world market
and demand has not risen on top of that
business in europe and china has slowed
down the united states until recently
one of the biggest importers has become
one of the biggest exporters of oil
fracking technology is tapping the vast
stocks of oil locked up in oil shale
and opec hasn't reduced its production
quotas either on the contrary saudi
arabia wants to expand production
saudi arabia is the world's biggest
producer of oil more than 500 billion
tons a year
it's followed by russia
and the united states which is the
world's third biggest producer
then come china and canada
is the fall in oil prices a temporary
phenomenon
low prices are already a problem for
some oil producing nations for example
for venezuela
oil has to cost an average of at least
120 dollars a barrel or venezuela will
eventually go bankrupt
117 dollars a barrel will keep nigeria
afloat the figure for libya is 110.
experts think russia would have
difficulties if the price remains under
100 a barrel
all these countries depend on income
from oil exports if the price remains
eighty dollars a barrel they're in
trouble although supply is increasing
consumption is falling
especially in europe engineers are
making car engines that are more
efficient and renewable sources of
energy are competing with oil and gas
so who are the winners from falling oil
prices
costs are falling for airlines and
container shipping so their profits are
rising
pharmaceutical and chemical
manufacturers pay less for raw materials
too
but the biggest winner is the individual
consumer who has more money left to
spend on other things
low oil prices are like a tax cut
so people don't seem worried about
dwindling oil reserves anymore the world
is swimming in cheap oil the only
question is
how long will this last